(lively music)
- Davos was the scene.
Everybody was there.
You have CEOs
from some of the biggest
companies in the world,
heads of state, the president was there.
I don't remember anyone
taking coronavirus seriously.
Everyone's always enthusiastic at Davos.
No one makes friends there
by predicting doom and gloom.
- This seems to be the
decade of shared success.
- [All] Together we can.
Together, we will.
- I was hesitant to say anything
because being a scientist,
driven by facts and data, the
absence of facts and data,
I didn't want to make any conjecture.
So I remember in retrospect,
I probably made statements
that were perhaps too neutral.
I think all the right
things are happening.
I mean, you've seen some of the actions
the Chinese government has taken.
I know critical disease control
agencies around the world
are getting really active.
So we all have to wait and see
there's a lot we don't know.
I don't think I was pressing it in saying
the economic trajectory of the US economy
would continue in 2020.
People are relatively
confident that global growth
will sustain through 2020.
The chance of an economic slowdown
barring some sort of an exogenous event.
We had an exogenous event.
I guess I was right about that.
- I remember watching CEO of
Goldman Sachs on the DJ booth
at a Salesforce party, just like 10 deep,
shoulder to shoulder.
It all feels like a totally
different planet now.
These are people who should have had
the best sight lines in the
world into what was going on.
These companies that
have operations in China,
where this virus had been
circulating for weeks.
And in retrospect, it
probably should have informed
how we approach things
here 'cause we were, what,
about two months behind them.
There was a sense that the
economy was just too strong
and America was just too resilient.
Even as some parts of the economy
are showing positive signs,
what happened during the month of March
will fundamentally
reshape American business
for the next decade.
March started on a very high note
and it ended with the economy
just incomplete taters.
And that 31 days where
just everything changed.
(orchestral music)
- [Woman] The coronavirus-
- [Man] Is fanning out
across Asia and Europe.
- [Woman] There may be additional
cases that we identified.
I do want to be imperative of that.
- [Man] Stocks, they
fell hard again today.
Economic fears, many
unknowns rattling investors.
- [Man] All non-essential businesses
shall close to their physical workplaces,
- [Woman] Police were
called after some customers
started fighting over
toilet paper and water.
- [Man] This is our new reality right now.
It is absolutely staggering
where we find ourselves.
(indistinct)
- How'd you get that?
- Happy to do it.
Happy to do it.
I want to be able to get back
and look at it for posterity's sake.
We're really good at opening hotels
but if you were to ask me
in the 36 or seven years
I've been doing this,
how many hotels have I
actually presided over closing,
it would be a very, very short list.
- I'm currently sitting actually
in the Baccarat lounge at Bellagio.
This building is vacant.
It's a bit surreal.
It's very different.
- This is our trading desk.
So for our agricultural commodities
and you can see that it is empty.
Typically it's very busy.
It's very noisy.
- We designed this headquarters
campus in which I'm sitting
for about 5,000 people.
Right now, there are roughly
300 people on a good day.
- I started putting out a
Friday note to employees
on Friday the 13th,
which was most people's
last day in the office.
It said Friday, March 13th,
I will stop comparing
this week to last week.
We are in unchartered territory.
First, take care of
yourselves and your families
as we run our business.
Follow company and local guidance.
Use judgment and humanity
with individual situations.
Show leadership with
people who are worried.
And remember, we have a company to run.
- I'm Chris Nassetta, CEO of Hilton.
- I'm the senior vice president
of corporate affairs at 3M.
- I'm the head of manufacturing
for Toyota Motor North America.
- I am the CEO of Novartis.
- I'm JetBlue's president
and chief operating officer.
- CEO and chairman of Proctor and Gamble.
- Chief executive officer
of IMAX Corporation.
- I am chairman and CEO of Cargill.
We're in the privileged
position of making food.
- Chairman and CEO of Goldman Sachs.
- Acting CEO and president
of MGM Resorts International.
- CEO of US Wealth
Management for JP Morgan.
- Deputy commissioner and
chief operating officer
of the NBA.
- So coming into 2020,
the US is in year 11 of the
longest economic expansion
since World War II.
Millions of jobs have
been added to the economy.
The stock market keeps
hitting record heights.
It looked like 2020 was
gonna be another good year.
- [Crowd] Three, two, one.
- New years going into 2020
felt like any other new year's.
We were seven months into our fiscal year
and things were going well.
- I was two weeks into my
job as a first time CEO.
- We had record Box Office
of over a billion dollars.
- You know, when we look back,
we see an auto market that
was pretty high actually.
- Our sales for plus 6%,
our earnings were plus 18%.
- We were looking forward
to bringing on a new aircraft type.
Now the Airbus 220.
- How we would evolve
the presentation of our game digitally.
- We were all sort of having
a similar conversation
about like, gosh times are good,
but there's just sort
of this haunting feeling
like something's out there.
- The pandemic showed that
strong economy that it was thin,
it was a veneer of shrink in
that companies were profitable,
making a lot of money
and unemployment was low.
But it really exposed these weaknesses
where wages had not really moved.
People are not by and large
wealthier than they were
10 years ago.
- The jobs that we saw grow the most
tended to be of the alternative variety.
There's contingent work, part-time work,
independent work, gig work.
And that also brought with it
a certain moment of fragility.
- Companies have spent
trillions of dollars
over the last decade
buying back their own stock
and paying dividends.
- Profits were growing.
But you might've worried
about, for example,
the rate of which companies
are not reinvesting into their businesses
or into the economy.
The classic case of a lot
of short-term orientation
without kind of big
investments into the future.
- The modern economy,
it's powered by technology
and it's this just in time,
it's perfectly efficient.
And in some ways it is,
and in some ways that's been really good
for consumers in particular,
but the flip side of
efficiency is resiliency.
If there's no fat baked in,
there's no cushion for
when things get bad.
- [Reporter] A mysterious
respiratory illness
has healthcare workers on alert.
At least 45 people have
contacted the virus
believed to be connected to animals
at a market in central China.
P&G has people all over China.
We don't have plants in Wu Han,
we have a distribution center.
So as soon as this happened,
our first concern was making sure
we took care of our employees.
- We knew there was some sort of
emerging viral issue in December.
Our health and safety
team had flagged in Wu Han
because we have five hotels in
Wu Han, something's going on.
- It felt like a just China issue for us
because a lot of what we make
is for domestic consumption.
And so certainly the
impacts that we looked at,
implications that we looked at
were largely limited to China
and perhaps parts of
Southeast Asia at that time.
- I don't think anybody thought
even when this was
impacting Macau in China,
that it would distance
itself, this close to us here
and end up in our ultimate shutdown.
- So there's this disconnect
between the sort of
bad rumblings out there
and the bad headlines coming
out of China and across Europe
and the US suffered.
It just keeps going up.
I mean, it hits record
high after record high.
In February looking back,
it seems like hubris,
but investors often don't see
what's right in front of them.
- Coronavirus was on the horizon,
but our investor day was
one of the most bolish
and exciting that we've ever had.
- I remember talking to a
very, very prominent investor
Superbowl weekend down in Miami,
where we had a discussion
with both of us said,
"Boy, it seems like
there's a lot more risk
"in this virus becoming a bigger issue
"than the market's pricing."
- On on February 11th, we've
been asked to participate
in the opening bell ceremony for NASDAQ
in celebration of our 20th anniversary.
- Happy 20th to JBLU.
- I had the pleasure of appearing
on Squawk Box in the morning
and was specifically asked
whether or not we were seeing
any impact from the coronavirus.
- You want to start with coronavirus?
- Sure.
- Is it really impacting things
in here in United States right now?
- For JetBlue, it's not impacting JetBlue
in any meaningful way.
Boy was I wrong?
And there a headline that
I think will live with me
until I retire from this industry.
- The Chinese government
basically shut the country down
and put the entire
populace under quarantine.
(tense music)
Now, that had an immediate impact
on Toyota's operations there.
We couldn't make cars,
we couldn't sell cars.
- We have over 700 screens now,
which is 1% of the screens in the country.
And Chinese new year is
the biggest film going week
for us of the year in China.
We typically do 10% of
our year in one week.
And then we heard every
theater in China was closed.
And then a day later, they said
none of the big Chinese
movies would be released.
What was the biggest part of our year
was reduced to nothing overnight.
- We produce about 70 billion
doses of medicine a year
in over 150 countries.
We had to make the decision
to send all of our China operations home,
which is over 10,000 people.
I think I began to wonder now,
this is something really big.
- Movement around China,
especially around the Ubed
province was being restricted.
So we had to let both our employees know,
and more broadly we communicated
that this could have a ripple effect
through other supply chains.
And it wasn't clear at that time
how significant it would be.
- We started having meetings
almost every other day
to really understand
how do we pull together the right teams,
assessing the demand, the
supply chain challenges.
We work together for
everything, from sourcing,
making sure that we had the
critical raw materials available
in order to be able to
manufacture respirators,
gearing up the equipment so
that we could run 24, seven
everywhere around the world.
- By the end of February,
we had mobilized a crisis management team.
I was meeting with my
CFO on a regular basis,
thinking very long and
hard about liquidity.
We were modeling every weekend,
looking at these numbers
that I think look horrific,
that looked like nothing I've ever seen
only to be outdone
by the numbers that I
saw the next weekend,
which only got outdone
by the numbers I saw the following week,
as it went further and
further into the abyss.
(mellow music)
- I remember the management team meeting
that I had with my team on March 4th,
where we all sat in the same
conference room together.
Jamie came and spoke to us for an hour
and he said to us,
"You should go read the history
"of the Spanish flu pandemic in 1918."
It was a early brush fire in
the spring summer of that year.
It kind of went away, and
then in the fall it came back
and it killed 50 million people.
And he said, this is going to be severe.
- 35 fatalities are linked
to the life care center
in Kirkland, that is the
hardest hit facility.
- When I saw pictures of that nursing home
outside of Seattle,
where families couldn't get
to see their family members
inside the nursing home,
because the virus had essentially
taken that facility over,
the heartbreaking pictures of people
with their noses pressed
up against the window
to try and communicate
with their loved ones,
that struck home with me.
- Airlines is where you
first started to see
the disruption from the virus.
- As we stepped into
March, we started seeing
a fairly rapid decline
of customer bookings,
an increase in customer
no-show rates and just
overall changing customer sentiment.
We knew we were in
something very different
than what we'd experienced before.
Very different than SARS,
very different than Zika
and quite frankly, very
different than nine 11.
- Our occupancies so quickly
from the third week in February
to the first week in
March, almost fell in half
in some of our luxury brands.
But it was really where
our group business was,
because of the international
visitation that was impacted.
- That time was a hectic time.
Early in March,
government started putting
restrictions on large gatherings.
That's when we started in
that early March timeframe,
really thinking about,
we may have to play games without fans.
- I sat down with my
CFO and I said to him,
"If the world shuts down, what
do our financials look like?
"What's our burn rate?
"How do we stop spending money?"
We called all our managers and
we said, "Cancel all costs."
We just said, stop it right now
because we don't know
what the future entails.
- We pulled all our
levers on liquidity early
because the reality is cash is king.
I don't know how deep it's going.
And so to protect the business,
I've got to make sure
that we have enough cash.
We have a billion 750 credit facility.
We pulled it.
(crowd cheering)
- I think this event for
us and the realization
of probably where we were going
hit the weekend of
March 8th, 9th and 10th.
We were fortunate,
we were hosting 15,000
people for a UFC fight.
We had Bruno Mars at the park theater,
but the reality was over at Mirage,
we were hosting a women's
leadership conference.
One of the guest speakers was
sick and contracted COVID-19.
A guest speaker at an event of scale,
about eight or 900 ladies
was in VIP receptions,
went to several restaurants,
went to several shows,
met many people, shook a
lot of our employees' hands.
It became a little daunting
into thinking about,
how are we going to
handle this going forward?
- When investors do finally
pull their head out of the sand,
they do it really quickly
and the market starts to tank fast.
So on March 9th, the
market barely gets open.
- [Woman] Trading has stopped.
Trading has stopped.
- Stocks fall so fast that it triggers
what we call a circuit breaker,
which is basically a time-out.
It was put in place after the 1987 crash.
And it's basically an automatic halt.
Everyone go back to your corner,
think about what you've done.
Take a deep breath and we'll
try this again in 15 minutes.
And it hadn't been traded in 20 years.
It was a sign that people were panicking.
Investors were running for the exits
and they couldn't get out fast enough.
March 11th for a lot of people
is the day that this became
real, very real, very quickly.
- We have the format the
assessment that COVID-19
can be characterized as a pandemic.
- To keep new cases from
entering our shores,
we will be suspending all travel
from Europe to the United
States for the next 30 days.
- On March 11th, we had a board meeting.
And the topic of that board meeting
was how we were gonna
deal with the coronavirus.
There was an understanding that yes,
we might actually have to
play some games without fans.
And at the time, it seemed unthinkable.
And then of course that night
is when we got our first confirmed
positive with Rudy Gobert
and we knew right then that
we had to suspend the season.
- The game tonight has been postponed.
You're all safe and take your time
in leaving the arena tonight
and do so in an orderly fashion.
- What brought a lot
of that home for people
was that they watched
it happen in real time.
There's still games happening.
- [Man] This is crazy.
This can't be true.
I mean it's not within the
realm of possibilities,
it's just the seem more like
out of a movie than reality.
- And then very quickly
people are looking at back
at a press conference
that Rudy Gobert had given
where he makes a joke
out of the whole thing
and is touching all these microphones.
It just starts to sink in
that this is not a joke.
- I remember thinking,
wonder what they're
gonna talk about on ESPN.
It's a sports network and
sports are shutting down.
And then thinking we sell food,
whether everything from
whether it's ground beef
or sweeteners that go into the sodas
that are served for these stadiums.
What's this gonna mean for our customers?
And you quickly go to start thinking about
second and third order consequences
as stadiums and restaurants
and places of public
gathering start to close.
What does that mean for our
customers for their business?
What does it mean for our business
and what does it mean for our employees?
- And March 12th was the last
day I've been in the office.
March 12th also was the day
that the market took a severe downturn.
And for our 5,000 advisors,
the average industry age of an
advisor are in their mid 50s
and they've seen many of these cycles
and many people remember 08 and 09.
But we also have a number of
advisors who were in their 30s
and they don't remember 08 and 09
and that likely was the
worst day of their career
and they hadn't seen volatility like that.
We also have a number of clients
who had probably never
seen volatility like that.
First-time investors.
- I was surprised at how
hard IMAX's stock got hit
'cause we were incredibly crushed.
Our stock had been trading
generally in the $20 range
and it went down to six or seven dollars
and within a matter of days.
When I was allowed, I
actually went into the market
and I bought some stock,
but I thought I would
also be sending a message
to our shareholders that
I believed in the company
and I believe we could survive this.
- March 12th stands out
and so far as I was on a flight to Boston
visiting with our crew
members on a pre-planned trip.
The questions being asked
changed almost overnight.
The questions our crew
members started asking
were not just about my health,
but am I going to have a job?
What's this going to do to JetBlue?
Can we survive this?
It all came to a crescendo
at that point in time
when you realize that this
is a much bigger thing
than anybody expected.
- We saw many of our advised
clients move and de-risk
and get into cash or short
term cash like strategies,
not surprisingly, particularly our clients
who are nearing retirement
just wanted to play it safe.
The advisors were still
going into the branches
because we were trying to
stay open for our clients
as long as possible.
Markets were super volatile.
People wanted to meet with their advisor.
- New York state on pause.
- A statewide order for
people to stay at home.
- We must enact an
immediate stay-at-home order
for the sake of Illinois.
- So there's a whole group of companies
whose business models
just don't make sense
when there's a pandemic going on.
Bars, restaurants, movie, theaters,
sports stadiums, casinos,
anything that involves
having lots of people
in close quarters just doesn't work.
So those shut down basically overnight.
- I made a lot of phone calls and I said,
we should be leaders in this.
Let's not wait.
We should be upfront that
it's the right message
that we're really concerned
about the health and
safety of our customers.
To be fair to the people I was talking to,
blockbusters were scheduled to open soon.
They had pre-sold tickets to theaters
and this lunatic is saying shut down.
- What happened in the early
into middle part of March
was we were constantly adjusting
to see if we could maintain production,
but there was a point in
time in that timeframe
where a number of
jurisdictions basically said,
we're shutting down.
Our pipelines by design are pretty thin.
We don't carry a lot of inventory.
That's the Toyota way.
Inventory is waste.
When our production
stopped, it had the impact
of almost drying up the typical
90 to 120 days worth of
inventory that we might have
for certainly for some of
our more popular models.
Now it's much less than that
in ways where we are living hand to mouth,
to make sure that we satisfy
the demand of customers.
We got one more bad news as you know,
the market went to heck.
Our occupancies were going down.
At one point, our forecast
for this building Bellagio
was like single digit.
It became clear to us that
we were gonna have to close.
In this state, we are
the largest employer,
largest payer of taxes.
We are this community's economy.
We had made a decision on
the 14th to close everything.
We notified the governor
on Sunday afternoon.
And by Sunday at six o'clock that night,
he had gone here in
Nevada on the television
and mandated a closure.
- The most effective course of action
is to direct all Nevadans to stay home
and for non essential businesses
to close to the public
for 30 days.
- We find ourselves in a closed mode.
For us, that means about 270
million a month in expenses.
It's our burn rate.
- There was no choice.
There was no business.
There were no revenues,
there was no demand.
Even if you'd been able
to reduce your workforce,
you still have to pay your debt service,
you still got to pay utilities and taxes
and all of these costs.
No business is built for zero revenues.
It's just not done.
- The Dow has its worst
single day of history.
I mean, just hundreds and
hundreds of billions of dollars
of stock market value is just evaporating.
- We were watching changes in markets.
We were watching companies
borrow more aggressively.
And one of the things that
we started talking about
was there always been a stigma
associated with borrowing
from the FED window.
So collectively the CEOs
of the eight large banks
got on a call together and we said,
does it make sense for
us to all just borrow
a nominal amount to show
that we're all in unison,
that this is not something
that should have stigma.
And if it's necessary to
keep the banking system
functioning smoothly for our clients,
we're all prepared to do it.
- [Bill] And Hilton is the
Canary in the coal mine.
This is an incredibly well capitalized,
amazing dominant global company
that actually doesn't own many hotels.
It just collects royalties.
Down from like 120 to 50.
Okay, it's going to zero
along with every other hotel company.
- Bill Ackman is a well-known
hedge fund investor.
He buys vixen companies,
and is pretty vocal about
his opinions on them.
He's positioned in Hilton.
And he went on CNBC and
said, among other things
that stock might go to zero.
- You say Hilton is going to zero, I mean.
- [Bill] 'Cause no business can survive
a period of 18 months without revenue.
- And as he's talking,
the market is just falling
and falling and falling
and it eventually triggers
another circuit breaker.
- I think he was trying to
make a point, which was,
people should be taking this
COVID-19 thing very seriously
because it could have
a devastating impact.
And reality is, he was right.
- We saw our revenue go
from nearly $20 million a day to zero
and even negative almost overnight.
A number of states
were putting into place
travel quarantines.
You had governors and others talking about
flying only for a central travel.
In March, our cash burn was
about $15 million a day.
When you start doing the math,
you realize very quickly
that there's an end point
where you just frankly, run out of money.
And the questions that we had to address
for our crew members were what
are we doing to cut costs?
Standing down projects, freezing hiring,
I'm looking at any lever we could pull
to try to reduce our cash burn.
It became very apparent
that the amount of
flying that we were doing
was going to have to be
reduced significantly.
And the operational
complexity of doing that,
it's not just limited to
changing people's shifts.
We have this fleet of over 260 aircraft.
And where do you park all those planes?
We needed to park them out in the desert.
- [Reporter] It was a record breaking fall
for US retail sales in March.
- And then there are companies
that are forced to shut down,
but like they don't have
any customers anymore.
There's just a total collapse in demand.
People stopped shopping.
They just stopped going to stores.
- [Reporter] This is the
biggest decline in retail sales
since the government started
keeping track at 1992.
- There were a lot of companies
that don't have the
option of shutting down.
They make things that people need.
- We are being asked by global
governments to stay open,
to make sure that food
could get to the consumers.
The food supply chain is complicated.
There's a lot of steps in the process
from the cattle ranchers
and poultry farmers
and the feed producers that
make the feed for the livestock
and the farmers that tend to the livestock
and then to the production facilities,
and then ultimately to
the transportation system
that bring them to the stores.
- [Reporter] The number
of coronavirus cases
in the United States is
growing exponentially.
- [Reporter] Store shelves
nationwide are dwindling
or totally empty.
- People start panic buying
anything and everything.
It starts to feel a
little bit like in times.
- Pre-loading their panic buying
increased consumption
beyond what we could make
in any given week and so
inventories were drawn down.
That did put a lot of
pressure into the system
for us to maximize production.
What we wanted to do is
get the assets that we had
running 24 hours a day, seven days a week
and they increased production
by several million cases
across our total system.
- These companies have to stay open.
Their first priority is
keeping their employees safe
and keeping the business operating.
- We moved quickly early on to
get as much PPE as we could.
Personal protective equipment
to take temperatures
amongst people going in and
if anyone showed any symptoms,
they could not go back in.
We added plastic shields in
between the workers on the line.
In the back of your mind,
you hold that optimism.
Maybe we'll get through this
with nobody getting impacted,
nobody getting infected.
But when you have 160,000
employees that are out and about
not only in our facilities,
but in their own communities,
you realize the odds of that are very low.
- And then there are the companies
that we're all turning to, to fix this.
You've got companies making
masks and respirators.
You've got pharmaceutical companies
who are getting to work on treatments.
So these are companies that
not only do they not have
the option of shutting down,
the entire world is
looking at them and saying,
this is not just a
business question for you.
This is an existential thing
that we need you to do.
You have to do a better
job than you used to do
and do it under unbelievably
trying circumstances.
- We have a few late stage
phase three clinical trials,
of repurposing medicines.
And then we have a very
large drug discovery effort
trying to see, can we find what we call
a pan-coronavirus drug that requires
new scientific discoveries,
new scale up new clinical trials.
And that is a much bigger challenge
because now you're asking
clinical trial sites
that are now focused on trying
to respond to a pandemic
to get a trial up and running.
Can you still enroll
patients into the study
if healthcare systems are closing down?
- A number of cases soaring just today.
More than 24,000 now nationwide
New Jersey today becoming the sixth state
to close all nonessential businesses.
- [Reporter] The president invoked
the Defense Production Act
to prioritize production of
items under government contract
and to allocate scarce items
where they are needed most.
- The order authorizes the head of FEMA
to acquire as many N 95
masks from the company, 3M
as is deemed necessary.
- We had significantly
increased the production rate
for respirators here in the US,
we'd gone from maybe 22 million in January
to more than 35 million in March.
We could see that this
was really coming at us
pretty fast here in the US.
So not only are we looking at
how do we continue to drive up
manufacturing of our own products,
but also what else can we do
from other parts of the world?
- So it doesn't take long
before you start hearing talk of bailouts.
- The airline industry alone,
seeking a $50 billion bailout,
but should these companies get relief
with no strings attached.
- The industry as a whole came
together in a remarkable way.
CEOs from every airline
were down in Washington,
trying to make sure that all
the decision makers understood
how vital and critical
the airline industry is
to this economy.
- We were number one,
really reinforcing with the administration
that the employment
situation was gonna be dire,
that our industry was gonna lose
millions and millions of jobs,
and we needed the federal government
to help take care of those teams.
- The employees are the
ones most hit by this.
When you lay off 62,000
employees, it's meaningful.
But I will give the
federal government credit.
The Cares Act came
together fairly quickly.
- Thank you all very much.
It's a very important day.
I've signed the single biggest
economic relief package
in American history and I must say,
or any other package by the way.
- So on March 27th, President Trump signs,
the $2 trillion coronavirus aid package,
the Cares Act into law.
This dwarfs any kind of stimulus
that was handed out during
the 2008 financial crisis.
So it includes billions
of dollars for airlines,
for hospitals, for state
and local governments.
It has a large, small
business lending program
that's meant to sort of keep paying people
who would otherwise have been laid off.
This is a massive amount
of government spending,
and it's meant to put a band-aid
over this broken economy.
Part of what we've had to
take a very hard look at
is how we make the payroll
dollars under the Cares Act,
work well for us and really
be clear with our crew members
about what we expect the future to hold.
- We have not ever advocated
for any sort of help from
the government for Hilton.
And so what we were advocating there
on behalf of our owners,
many of whom are small medium-sized,
entrepreneurially based businesses was,
we needed to help create
a bridge of liquidity
to help them get to the other side.
- One of the things that's so interesting
about the monetary and fiscal policy
is it's really created liquidity
and support for large businesses.
It's allowed large businesses,
even those that are in distress
to finance forward, very, very actively.
But small businesses and
especially very small businesses
are just devastated by this crisis.
- And the worst part is by late March,
it's clear that this isn't over
and that it's time to
start packing sandbags.
- We had around $380 million in cash,
and we looked at our burn
rate and we concluded
that without massive layoffs
and things like that,
we probably spend about
$10 million a month.
So we looked at it and we said,
we have about two and a half years
and a zero revenue environment.
And that was a really
important element for us,
because at that time, the
street and constituencies
were really focused on how
long companies could survive
and would they be going out of business?
And I think that was a really
important message for us,
that we had the money to survive.
- We were fortunate last year,
we sold off about $8 billion
worth of real estate.
With that $8 billion,
we sold down some debt,
but between what we left and
a bond offering we just did
for 750 million, we're
sitting on about 4.6 billion
in capital and liquidity.
So we have money to sustain us
and it will guide what
we do going forward.
- The thing that's really
different about this pandemic
is that it is global and that
the demand has been so high.
Quadrupling of capacity or output from 3M
is still not sufficient.
The increase in manufacturing
from even some of our competitors
is still not sufficient
to meet the demand.
- A lot of focus came on
the meat production industry
because so many facilities
had been shutting down.
- Union officials now say
164 of the nearly 900 workers
at the Cargill meat packing plant
have tested positive for the coronavirus.
- The facility we closed in Pennsylvania
came back on after 17 days
and is back running again.
So I think that's the best
thing we can do as an industry
is get adequate testing,
continue to have adequate PPE,
but get the plants up and
running as quickly as possible
so that store shelves can stay stocked.
- There's really no way in a
pandemic to keep everyone safe
if people have to be gathering.
If they have to be working in a factory
or working in a retail
store, there's always risk.
- What kept us up at
night was figuring out
if there was in fact,
a safe and healthy way
to return to play.
There was no guarantee that
you can do it in 100% safe way.
And so this is literally
matters of life and death.
And so that weighs on you
because you don't want
to put anybody at risk.
That is what makes the weight
of these decisions so heavy.
- We lost an Empire casino,
one of our places back in New
York, we lost the horseman.
And so it was actually the
first death within our family.
It just took on a different
context from that point
and you began to realize
the responsibility
of you're not only
accountable to a business,
but at this point, you're
accountable for lives.
- And we lost our first crew member,
that frightened so many crew members,
but also brought home the
reality of this pandemic
and that it wasn't going away.
- One of the stories
that that really hit me
was the first death we had at
one of our production sites.
I think this was a moment
where it became very real
that we have this
difficult balance to walk.
We make these medicines
that hundreds of millions
of people depend on
and yet at the same time, we
want to protect the people
who come bravely into the office,
into the manufacturing sites
or our clinical trial sites,
where the healthcare
workers were working bravely
to keep the hospitals running.
- There's no magic bullet.
There's no magic vaccine or therapy.
It's just behaviors.
- On March 31st, last day of the month,
the US overtakes China in
the official death count.
Total number of confirmed cases
at that point are 160,000,
which is the most of any
country in the world.
American business comes into March
riding an 11-year economic expansion.
By the end of the month,
the economy is in tatters,
10 million people had lost their jobs.
- Unemployment numbers are
at unprecedented levels.
- [Reporter] The drive-through,
a symbol of America's capitalist invention
now being used to process
its millions of unemployment.
- Literally, about a
third of American workers
were vulnerable, vulnerable
either to being laid off,
vulnerable to furloughs,
vulnerable to reduced work hours.
Now that's clearly a much larger number
than actual unemployment.
- The 500 largest companies
in the US are worth
$3 trillion less than they
were before the month began.
The market, which has just
been at all time highs
in February is officially
in a bear market territory,
20% off from the peak.
- The pandemic closed
the book on one chapter
for American business.
The decade that proceeded it
was one of the most successful in history
and it ended quickly.
That's a lot of whiplash
for business to absorb.
- Given our access to information
because we have such a
big footprint in Asia
why did all of us and by
the way, not just all of us,
but so many feel that the chance of this
spreading into a global pandemic was low?
We all tend to look at things
through a lens of the
experiences that we've had.
- The difference is we are
much more globally connected
from air travel, the way
supply chains work now
than perhaps 10 or 12 years ago
when SARS and MERS were
really taking place.
We've seen the market hit record high
after record highs since March,
but there's a lot of rebuilding to do.
And companies are now grappling
with what kind of foundation
they're rebuilding on.
- What might prove to be
features of the economy
coming out of this,
one is the idea of what do we think of
as essential infrastructure,
essential capabilities for our company?
We've now all rediscovered that in fact,
the probably the most
essential infrastructure
in this moment, as I said,
digital infrastructures.
I don't think you're
going to see investments
in digitization slow down, actually.
I think they may continue to accelerate.
- One of the things that
we're thinking about
is how do you continue to engage fans?
How do you continue to engage
people who love your sport,
who can't actually there physically?
And this is why technology, I think
and the integration of that technology,
those are the kinds of innovations
that have come out of this pandemic.
- I think one of the capabilities
that I think companies are going to now
have to think hard about and build for,
which is how do we build resilience,
even if it comes at the
expense of some efficiency.
- The Toyota way of production,
including just in time supply of parts
or more rigorous focus on
very efficient manufacturing,
that's not going to change.
What may change within that is
how we support our partners,
our suppliers, to be resilient
in order to provide just in
time parts and production.
- It takes in a place like
this, in Bellagio about 70%
normally just to break even.
Even these are large ships, if you will.
And so to the extent
we're not in that mode,
we're probably not making money.
Our principle is going to be,
it's going to be some
time before we get there.
And so how can we look at this operation?
How can we look at this
business and regear it
so that we can do that
much more effectively
at a much lower occupancy rate?
- I think there's been some
other different kinds of changes
at the level of society and the economy
is becoming even more apparent
about the often the
disconnect that happens
between successful corporations
and successful parts of the economy
and the parts of society
that get left behind.
Those might've been abstract
kind of conversations
in a kind of theoretical abstract way,
but I think most business leaders
have come into personal
direct experience with that
in this moment.
- This won't last forever
and some companies will be better for it.
Some will be stronger for
having sort of planned
and been flexible and gotten through it
and some will just never come back.
- As an investments business,
we teach our clients to
look at the long-term goal,
and I think that's how you run a business.
You run a business for the long-term.
You're prepared for the worst.
This was the worst.
(tense music)